monza est choisi on croyait pas je crois
que tout le monde s'exprime aujourd'hui
on se retrouve sur soc part comme vous
l'avez deviné dans cette intro cartman a
finalement voulu prendre ma place
oui c'était cartman ce n'était pas moi
non et voici notre perso monsieur moche
montre-toi n'ai pas honte
il est horrifiant enfin perso vraiment
dégueulasse alors ta mère tu as demandé
d'aller au lit alors vas-y avant d'être
puni - maman par doha voilà une petite
chambre bien tranquille avec notre sol a
mis le poisson rouge est un bon freinage
se coucher cauchon nous
bonne nuit ma petite boule de gomme aux
mondiaux indoor de nombreux voleurs de
slip
pourquoi d'évident voleurs de slip
je crois que l'on les au maire délégué à
l'économie tente de me tuer mais
j'hallucine
on va leur montrer de quoi on est
capable je propose d'envoyer une toupie
voilà parfait en deux tomes de merde
merde il est trop gros on ne peut pas le
battre donc ce sorcier vaudou rétrécir
puisqu'on en parle du style du sorcier
qu'est ce que c'est que ça est-ce qui va
de notre époque oui je serai plus fort
que vous et en plus en pyjama j'aille à
vous battre
c'est bon on les a eus alors qu'est ce
qui se passe et ce qu'on récupère nos
six lits pour moi un escroc et l'inde au
slip niveau 10 on a passé un petit
niveau devrons faire un petit bruit de
fond le jeu voilà c'est des combats au
tour par tour on ramasse de l'argent et
des équipements sur les ennemis qu'on a
tué ou alors on peut en acheter à des
vendeurs on débloque des aptitudes et
des points d'amélioration par exemple la
hache peut débloquer une nouvelle
attitude plaies d'égypte là on part sur
un équipement plutôt pas mal on est un
jeune homme
berglund du swat
juste là une petite sacoche et ben voilà
un et on peut même s'envoler avec des
oreilles pareil y'a pas de problème mais
les oreilles les messieurs moche mais tu
es encore plus moche pensée passes
impossibles à qu'est ce que tu as toi
mais je te tutoie le juif j'ai dessous
attention c'est impressionnant surtout
venant de la part de ce personnage c'est
carrément pas crédible et empiler morts
bon c'est un rat en même temps on peut
dire que c'est quelque chose
d'incroyable on a tué un rat bon je
trouve parfois que vous devrez lui dire
la vérité
mais s'il a réellement ce dont il le
découvrira par lui même de toute façon
je suis lessivé est ce que tu veux mais
comment bien de faire l'amour j'assure
ma chérie est long mais c'est sérieux ça
avec cette tête de psychopathe je suis
les céréales killer aux oreilles
décollées je vais te tuer aurait tout
moquer bâtard arrêter les bruits de fond
dégueulasse qu'est ce que tu veux tu
veux des sous aux ébats tu auras mon ap
tentons maison alors j'ai pas précisé
mais il ya plusieurs classes guerrier
voleur mage est juif et moi j'ai pris
juif un plat a terminé à l'est j'ai cru
qu'il y avait des bruits ou dans ma
chambre mais ça vient de ce buteur du
jeu je dois en train de me dire qui
copulent mon appartement a fait
attention
j'ai un morceau de câbles non
électriques un arrêté de copuler hockey
une petite porte mais non moi j'aime
retrouver dans la chambre mais voilà le
butin a retiré sa carrière laure a déjà
trouvé les gnomes
c'est l'heure du dos du duel mais quand
vous voyez vous je me consentir ou pas
ça va pas du tout allez c'est qui le
patron un papa maman arrêté à y associer
mais regardez arrête et on arrête de te
balance au dessus de moi
what c'est quoi cette attaque
c'est quoi ça je me fais attaquer par
les testicules comme un raid tétons ça
m'énerve
et voilà il est mort sur ces voleurs de
slip or moi mon slip
d'accord c'est bon tu as gagné prends ça
tu pourras répression grandir intégrer
qu'est ce que c'est cette scène vous
imaginez c'est un petit de 8 ans et demi
vol le jeu à ses parents et tombe sur
cette scène écrasé retrouver kyle je
vais retrouver calme
ils sont au moins dix s'est rien passé à
bande de menteurs savasta mais
normalement il ya un allié aux choix
qu'ils accompagnent salut c'est pas moi
salut mec j'ai pas du bonhomme de neige
et une demande en habiller parce que oui
on a une sorte de mur facebook un peu
holla holla très bien bon en gros il ya
une guerre qui se prépare un regard de
l'ue sur son trône arrête de te la péter
bon voilà on doit trouver des filles ont
reporté des filles pour elle à la guerre
sous les filles
google s'impose acheter à faire le
nouveau tu veux pas avoir d'ennuis fois
je comprends pas un peu je suis super
beau gosse pourquoi leur ai juste comme
ça
soyons francs cette fille là est ce
qu'elle est pas pire que mon perso
physiquement bien sûr que sir donc là il
ya stade avec nous qui nous aident pour
le combat et on peut même changer de
poste alors y en a qui d'autre là où
jimmy ça peut être marrant je veux le
bruit marron tant redouté desserra le
gros colons de tout ce qu'ils entendent
qu'est ce que c'est que ça what
qu'est-ce qui fait
à thème tabasser les filles qui m'a
agressé
désolé c'est le chat en temps non
c'était pas moi jimmy c'était pas moi
qui ai fait ça bon sens que je peux
recruter les filles tu veux parler aux
filles maintenant oui écoute bien
nouveau d'effroyables rumeurs circulent
en ville alléguant que notre bonne
copine aline delsaut aurait fréquenté la
clinique d'avortement
si monica s'étonnera guère cette fois
alors que c'est une [ __ ] manipulatrice
approche toi de cette mission et les
princesses se pencheront sur ta
roquettes
ok on arrête j'ai envie de prendre
cartman avec moi comment chabrol ah oui
oui oui à la voici enfin voila j'ai vu
de profil facebook de long en large et
je pense que tu as un garçon très
intéressant ou salle on le savait petit
[ __ ] de manipulatrice hypocrite
heureusement qu'on a envoyé une
nouveauté ce n'est pas vrai les filles
alors comme ça on veut baiser la petite
amie non ok c'est parti on se fait
couple saisit au plat ça c'est fait on
n'en parle plus vieille europe
bon je suis de retour je veux retourner
voir les filles pour leur dire ce que
j'ai vu c'est bon tu es sûr de vous
apporter ça et bien sûr quel est le
problème
oui c'en est un oui ok ne voit un
fouteur de hacking avortement et trouve
la salle des archers prend en photo tous
les dossiers bonjour vous êtes là pour
un avortement
ce que tout ira bien des craintes - fois
toujours la plus récente ça la 2e porte
à gauche capable il peut pas
m'accompagner bonjour je sais docteur
loving you bad teacher ça ne sera pas
long dit tu es prochaine par un
avortement non ne t'inquiète pas on a un
siège rehausseur mais pas morte est bien
détenteur on va tester cette saloperie
en voiture simone
ah bah oui je suis un homme tu va cramer
l'aspirateur la loi je répare ce truc a
voulu ma portée c'est bon j'ai les
fringues
perso si ce médecin veut m'aider je lui
dirai non accès autorisé merci docteur
web via les dossiers de 2013
un espion ou là qu'est ce qu'il fait là
à bagnolet vial est intervenue ok
travail et un truc à la manche vous qui
se passe dans cette clinique moi je me
retrouve mignon tout ça est lui encore
plus ce qu'est ce qu'il fait là très
bien la clinique et maintenant infectées
par le virus zombie nazi
ok c'est carrément le bordel bon ben on
va passer dans le petit trou 1 op la
déraison biladi au pôle à moins de rats
as quoi ça mon gars bien foetus ya plus
de foetus mais quoi mais même des
guillaume nazis à la plus vous avez des
slips sur eux quant à elle tenté de
voler des slips bordel ok donc là
attention parce que on peut faire des p
exactement comme ça j'en ai marre de
voir des pieds au dessus de moi
mais qu'est ce qui fait lui ait fait
style qui se veut avorter
aa je suis pas pour une opération à vous
voilà docteur c'est quand vous voulez
voyons si c'est un vrai docteur feu lui
un avortement se dépêchent à mais
pourquoi pourquoi fois l'avortement
assez horrible
à puis va choper de maladies avec le
nombre de boutons que j'ai sur la
tronche j'espérais quoi ah je veux
presser très bien non merde j'ai perdu
parce que je vais aspirer c'est bowles
il l'a fait qu'est ce que j'espérais
absolument rien sortez immédiatement
très bien il ya du zombie nazi
oh mon dieu mais nord les noms des
foetus je suis là pour toi mon pote
batteur geof ces bébés sont en train de
sucer son sens oui c'est un peu ça on va
se faire tranquillement il les laisser
tuer les gens n'ont même effectué ce
combat engagé plaies d'égypte heures hop
hop hop hop marteau du chaos bloc
olala où les animals ils sont morts
regardez les constructions foetale watts
ou
c'est quoi si avoue bien aux mondieux
les immenses mais le bébé il a 44 ans et
demi va faire injurier dessus pour la
sauver j'espère au moins que ça va vous
faire pour la sauver
là où l'église est l'enfoiré de merde
professeur carreau elle nous vient nous
en aide sommes ok on a un bouclier c'est
pas mal on l'a eu un petit boss la part
un gros boss le talent de sa tête et ce
qui nous donne rien un affront tkc son
crâne
je veux un butin donne moi des
équipements dans sa tête il veut la
place pour mettre une armurerie blachère
your tempi schéma inverse bonjour trop
bas dans ce bâtiment dégage
et voilà les gens j'espère cette petite
vidéo sur ce spot vous aura plu parce
que vous m'avez demandé encore encore
encore de faire des vidéos sur ce jeu et
j'avoue que j'en avais envie dit tous au
revoir à monsieur moche qui est
d'ailleurs devenue madame auch
actuellement arrête
ah si je vous intéresse il est dispo sur
ps3 xbox 360 et pc j'ai oublié de dire
comme à chaque vidéo j'oublie toujours
de dieppe
sur quoi elle loge et auquel je joue
j'espère que ça vous aura plu dégage
mais que tout le monde puisse à bientôt
une nouvelle vidéo j'ai reçue par la
cabinet
m